what's going on guys this is rob and uh
spoiler alert right ending explained
that kind of denotes there will be
spoilers but i feel like we have to save
for some people so spoiler alert for
this um the ending of the batman was
great because if you know what you're
looking for
i feel like they're setting up for one
of the most interesting batman stories
to happen in recent memory from dc
comics so talking about this ending for
a second as most of you guys know uh
when it turned out that riddler was
basically captured and then he was
thrown into arkham asylum which looks
rough like i mean just from what little
we saw of arkham asylum it looks like
hell
it looks like a pretty brutal place but
in the cell that he was in the cell next
to him was housed by a villain
and in an interview that was recently
done with matt reeves although i don't
think we really needed to be told this
villain was of course the joker now one
of the things matt reeves said is that
the joker is not really expected to
appear in the sequel at least that
seemed to be the impression he was
giving off and i think that's a smart
move but the the storyline that i'm
talking about with regards to what it is
that
essentially they're leading up to is a
story called the war of jokes and
riddles and this story
was
every bit as awesome as you think it is
based on the name right the war of jokes
and riddles was absolutely incredible i
loved it kite man hell yeah i loved kite
man
he kind of had a little bit of an
appearance before that but uh kite man
was cool he was like this small time guy
who basically became a criminal but like
he would he literally just kind of flew
around on a kite and he would just yell
like kite man hell yeah and like rob
people and stuff like that he was like
the dc comics equivalent of like the
condiment king those of you guys
remember him for batman the animated
series the condiment king absolutely
loved that guy so here's the idea behind
this right talking about the war of
jokes and riddles for a second the cool
thing about this story is that it was
actually told in hindsight it was
basically around the time that batman
was supposed to marry catwoman and then
i guess she bailed i don't remember
exactly how it was that whole thing
happened but the important thing here is
that he was telling catwoman this story
about the early days when he was batman
i think it was like his second year or
third year or something like that and
how basically things had popped off in
such a way to where he ended up
basically in like this giant gotham-wide
conflict with the riddler and the joker
waging war against each other now it
didn't initially start out that way
instead what had happened is the riddler
and the joker actually intended to work
together in order to take out the batman
but because of the fact that they
basically had disagreements over how it
was going to be done they ended up going
to war against each other in a lot of
ways it was just kind of like a mini
version of civil war for marvel comics
instead of it being like the whole
superhero community which is actually a
story called kingdom come which is
amazing instead it was basically just a
more confined story among the various
villains that existed in the batman
mythos and by and large the villains as
they existed in a relatively primitive
form meaning they were still fairly new
to actually being villains they were
split among lines right so one group
sided with the joker one group sided
with the riddler some of it was
self-preservation right which one they
thought had the best possible chance of
overcoming the other some of it was
because they agreed with the others
ideologies there were all kinds of
different motivations behind it but
batman was basically stuck in the middle
because this war was not just the joker
and the riddler fighting each other it
was the joker and the riddler fighting
each other plus trying to fight batman
and at the same time the people of
gotham city were basically caught in the
crossfire and so it was one of those
things where batman is like trying to
defeat the riddler and he's trying to
defeat the joker and he's trying to keep
himself alive and he's trying to keep
the people of gotham city safe there was
a lot going on in this whole thing now
can you transfer this to the robert
pattinson batman films yes but i feel
like this should be a third batman movie
and the reason why is because i could
see them introducing villains in the
second batman film and not every villain
has to be like a hallmark villain but it
can be one of these things where they
build off existing knowledge of them for
example we don't need a movie where
batman fights the joker will it make
money sure but we don't need the joker
explained to us one because the joker is
the most popular comic book villain of
all time like quite literally topping
every single chart and then two
the joker's just popular among people
who don't even read comics right i mean
heath ledger's joker solidified that if
ever there was anybody who had never
seen like caesar romero's joker from
back during the old uh adam west batman
tv show if they were ever unsure about
like the the mannerisms or the nature of
the joker how crazy he is heath ledger
fixed all that so people could literally
go into it whether it's from him or
joaquin phoenix or whatever the joker
can just appear right and then just side
with the riddler and like call it a day
and we basically know what the joker's
about so we don't need like the ins and
outs of his character we already know
what's going on with the riddler so we
have that whole question answered all
this left to do here is basically fill
in the gaps now do i think that like
batman 2 should be a sort of you know
great big huge event where like batman
is fighting all these different
criminals
maybe right possibly it's entirely
possible that like batman 2 could just
be like villains escaping or something
along those lines or some kind of
situation unfolds because of the actions
of the riddler it basically leads to
chaos and gotham where the riddler was
like one of the first and now all these
people are coming out of the woodwork
that batman's never really heard of
before some of whom are small time guys
kite man conor mcking things like that
other ones are bigger people harvey dent
being splashed in the face and basically
becoming uh two-faced things along those
lines right because as far as i'm aware
in this movie there was no reference to
the actual character of two-face so
again you get these small little things
here and there right these possibilities
on what you can get in different
villains being introduced even then the
nature of the war of jokes and riddles
doesn't really even have to be a movie
that has like a whole bunch of batman
villains on one side and a whole bunch
of batman villains on the other would it
be cool sure what it could be is the
joker and his guys waging war against
the riddler and his guys and that's it
right and batman's just trying to put
out fires everywhere i mean the first
batman movie like this one that we just
saw literally showed us what happened
when one guy wreaks havoc on an entire
town christopher nolan's batman trilogy
with like bane or scarecrow or the joker
showed us what happened when one guy
wreaked havoc on a town so it's not that
far outside the realm of possibility
that having two guys wreaking havoc
would cause all kinds of different panic
and pandemonium and it's just one of
those things i mean the idea of the war
of jokes and riddles in movie form
just sounds great and i can't really
imagine very many scenarios as to why
they would introduce or even tease the
possibility of like a joker in a riddler
team up if that wasn't going to be the
case because literally he's like we
could work together and destroy the
batman the riddler's like yeah you know
and like that's basically it it also
seemed like the joker was kind of
messing with riddler a little bit to
kind of bring him in or at least you
know just be like hey man don't worry
you'll get your turn you know you'll be
able to destroy the batman sometime he
will fall eventually you know something
along those lines again if you wanted to
do it that way it could be that like the
riddler and the joker the way the joker
betrays the riddler is like yeah sure
let's team up but we know that joker's
crazy as hell we know that joker's
schemes make sense to no one but himself
and it's not that far outside the realm
of possibility that the joker would put
on this perception that he's teaming up
with the riddler just in time to escape
and then turns against the riddler it's
like anybody's going to kill batman it's
going to be me but again we don't really
know what role the joker is going to
have in the future of the robert
pattinson batman films the fact that it
seems like he's not going to appear in a
sequel is a pretty big thing because it
means either he's not really going to
appear at all or they're saving him for
something because the joker is one of
these characters where if they're like
okay we made a billion dollars on batman
one let's have robert patton said meet
the joker it's gonna be a billion and a
half dollars right because if there's
one thing that people love it's seeing
batman fight the joker it's just a
hallmark of like batman movies he's got
to fight the joker at some time it
seemingly happened in virtually every
iteration of any kind of batman movie
series ever it happened in like batman
89 didn't really happen subsequently
after that because jack nicholson's
joker died uh it happened in the
christopher nolan dark knight trilogy
and it looks like it's gonna happen here
it even kind of happened in suicide
squad a little bit but not necessarily
like it's one of those things just sort
of happens right and it's just one of
those things that you expect so having
the two of them face off against each
other would be cool but regardless let
me know what you guys think right would
you guys want to see a movie where it's
like batman 3 and it's basically the war
of jokes and riddles it's the riddler
and the joker either teaming up to
destroy batman initially and then going
to war against each other or for
whatever reason just going to war
against each other right off the bat and
batman and gotham are caught in the
middle let me know what you guys think
but with that being said we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace